[Music]
when I tell people that I'm a wrestler
they don't really believe me at first I
don't know what image they have in their
head of what a wrestler should look like
especially when I say I'm the super
heavyweight for women's wrestling and
they're like you wrestle like you're
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle and
so it's always interesting to make them
like what did you expect my name is
adilyn gray I'm a three-time world
champion ranked number one in the world
been undefeated for two and a half years
and I'm gonna compete in the Rio Olympic
Games in August I never really
considered the Olympics as an option for
me when I was younger kid and it's
something that I don't think enough
girls have an opportunity to dream about
[Music]
I want to redefine feminine to some
extent and and to have people challenge
the way they look at the word strong and
not just see a boy that pops into your
head
I started wrestling boys I was six years
old and I wrestled boys all the way
through high school and I think I earned
a lot of respect from a lot of the
teammates out there who did lose to me
or maybe beat me and I got to train with
the best guys in the world and they made
me tougher they made me work for every
single point I had to wrestle with and
and they made it so that I could be a
champion on the women's level now we
teach girls to be perfect and boys to
take risks I need to take risks that I
am a confident strong female who knows
that I'm great at wrestling I'm still
struggling with that concept that I'm
worried about not being perfect when I
step on the mat
[Music]
I have to step on that mat and make sure
that I work every single moment to win
an Olympic gold medal I want young girls
to be able to look at thatmy situation
and be able to dream about it I'm
excited for that moment to have my five
risen and and be able to know that I'm
gonna hold a gold medal around my neck
[Music]
you
[Music]